Prof: Okay,
well today we're just winding
down.
First of all,
a few concluding reflections to
wrap up the course.
Well, we've now traced the
development of a society,
of a political culture and
indeed, in many ways,
a whole national culture,
over more than 200 years,
250 years.
I promised when we started off
in lecture one that we'd be
looking at some great
personalities,
some great events and some
great processes,
and I hope that that promise
has been met.
We've had the great
personalities,
warts and all,
with or without heads.
We've also traced a changing
political culture:
the development of the
institutions of representative
government;
the eventual taming of personal
monarchy;
the development of concepts of
the rule of law,
of political participation,
of notions of liberty under the
law.
We've also looked at the
emergence,
the early stages of the
emergence, of a fully capitalist
market economy,
and indeed its connections to a
nascent world economy.
And we've looked at the
transition from a late medieval
society of orders to what can
reasonably be described as a
nascent class society.
We've looked at a
transformation in religious
culture, the eventual acceptance
of a tentative pluralism and
toleration in matters of belief.
And of course we've looked at
enormous changes in levels of
education, in popular literacy
and the print culture that
served these and so on.
And throughout all of this,
in many ways,
we've looked at the hammering
out of the conflicts to which
all of these processes gave
rise.
And eventually,
the finding of ways to deal
with those conflicts peaceably.
Well, these are things of some
significance.
They matter,
most obviously,
to the extent that some of the
events and processes that we've
been examining in this period
have left a legacy in the modern
world in terms of institutions,
in terms of values,
in terms of ideas.
And that's not just true of
England or Britain,
but also of a larger world that
at one time or another was
subject to British influence,
firsthand or at secondhand.
To that extent,
many of these things are a
widely shared legacy and worth
knowing something about.
They are, in the words of one
Tudor chronicler,
in his definition of history,
they're "tales useful to
be known."
And all that is one form of
what Peter Laslett,
in his famous phrase,
described as
"understanding ourselves in
time."
But when he used that phrase,
he also meant something larger.
He meant reflecting on the
actual nature of the historical
process.
Now, of course one can do that
for any period of history for
any country;
they're all equally valuable as
human experience,
though the stories and the
meanings vary.
We've looked at one particular
case, but it also serves to
illustrate some general points
about the historical process and
I'll raise them briefly.
First, of course,
history is process.
We're looking at societies
which are in constant motion.
Change is the heart of the
matter.
People change,
societies and their
institutions change,
their values change,
their identities change.
An outline course of this kind
helps to reveal that,
and early modern England
certainly illustrates that
general truth.
It was a time obviously enough
of the breaking of worlds and of
the making of worlds,
of the erosion of old
certainties and identities and
structures,
and the creation of new ones.
But secondly,
historical change of this kind
is messy.
It's complex and messy and,
in many ways,
ambiguous.
History is never scripted in
advance.
Historians who have an
ideological cast of mind might
like to pretend that it is and
to describe historical processes
as though they have a certain
inevitability,
leading to preconceived ends of
one kind or another.
But they deceive themselves.
Nothing in history is
pre-ordained.
Some change may be the
successful outcome of
deliberately planned action,
but a great deal is the result
of improvised responses to
immediate contingencies.
And in both cases,
there are always the unforeseen
consequences.
The history of early modern
England illustrates this well
enough.
Think of the Henrician
Reformation,
or think of the regicide and
what followed it,
or think of the long working
out of the outcome of the
Revolution of 1688.
So it's not scripted in advance
and it's not synchronized
either.
Change of different kinds
proceeds at different paces.
We've looked at political
change, economic change,
social change,
cultural change.
We've seen the urgency with
which political change can often
take place,
but then there are also those
processes which are of a very
gradual,
very slow and cumulative
nature, worked out over
generations and uneven in their
long-term impact.
Think of the uneven spread of
literacy, for example,
or the process of economic
change that I've looked at.
As a result,
at any one point in time,
any society is a kind of
mixture of forms because change
is uneven, because it's partial.
So, the process is messy,
but nonetheless,
in all of this one can find
patterns, one can trace
connections.
If it wasn't so,
one would not be able to offer
interpretations of the process
of change.
One wouldn't be able to offer
arguments about the nature of
causation.
And again, looking at a
particular society over a long
period of time helps one to
appreciate this aspect of the
study of history.
It reveals the interconnections.
It reveals the way things work
their way through over time.
But no single interpretation
ever encompasses it all,
of course.
No single interpretation ever
holds all the answers.
How can one simply answer a
question like,
"When did England become
Protestant?"
And what did that mean, anyway?
That's why, of course,
we constantly need to revise
our views of it all in the light
of new evidence,
in the light of new imaginative
insights on the part of
historians.
We can never wholly recover the
past;
it's gone, it's drowned in time.
But we can enter a dialog with
the evidence that it has left
and,
by doing that,
remake the past again and again
in the present,
according to our changing
preoccupations and our changing
understandings.
Finding new dimensions of what
was going on,
previously neglected;
finding new meanings,
new understandings.
And this is very evident in the
ongoing debates over all the
major issues of this particular
period,
and the way that new issues are
constantly emerging.
Well, it's because of that
complexity that I've tried to
present an account of change in
this period that is complex and
many faceted,
that includes many dimensions;
the political,
the economic,
the social,
the cultural,
each of them making its own
contribution to an overall
process,
each of them helping to make
the overall process
comprehensible.
And it's because of the
ambiguities in all of this that
I've tried to adopt a variety of
perspectives;
looking at things from the
Catholic point of view and from
the Protestant point of view,
from the monarchical,
from the populist;
history as viewed from the top,
or from the bottom,
or from the middle;
history wearing breeches,
history dressed in a gown.
And there's a point to all of
this;
the point is simply that
history contains many stories,
all of which deserve to be
told.
It contains,
in the evidence it leaves to
us, many voices,
all of which deserve to be
heard.
No one owns the past;
it's common land.
There's no velvet rope denying
access.
It's not a gated community.
The dead, in the evidence they
leave to us, will talk to
anyone.
They're very nice that way.
I've also tried repeatedly to
give a sense of the context
within which people lived,
made their decisions and
choices, and acted.
And again, there's a very
simple historical philosophy
behind that which is neatly
stated in the old adage that
people make their own history,
but they don't make it just as
they choose.
They make it within contexts
and under conditions that are
not of their own choosing;
some of which are inherited,
some of which are newly
encountered, some of which can
be anticipated,
some of which take them by
surprise.
But by their actions and
responses and choices,
they can change their world,
though always within certain
constraints.
And to understand that process
and the outcomes,
we need to understand the
context within which people
acted in their own time,
in their own ways,
according to their own lights.
One of the most important of
such contexts is of course the
structures of power in any
society, in determining action,
in initiating change.
Some people carried more
weight, some had more clout;
we've seen examples enough of
that in early modern England in
the political sphere,
in the economic sphere and
elsewhere.
But we've seen examples too of
the fact that power can be
resisted, it can be confronted,
it can even be put under
restraint.
People make their own history,
they can alter the contexts,
sometimes quite significantly,
reshaping the world that is
encountered by the next
generation,
and that in a sense has been
the core of the narrative
element of this course.
So to conclude:
things change,
change is messy,
it's ambiguous in its meaning,
there are many interconnected
stories,
history has many voices,
people make their own history,
but not just as they please,
and if some have more power
than others to call the shots,
they don't have to have it all
their own way;
nor did they.
Reflecting on the process as a
whole gives the history of any
period and any country its
meaning,
its many meanings,
and that's why it's worth
bothering.
In studying history,
we constantly reconstruct the
past in the present,
disciplined as we do it by
respect for the evidence which
it leaves to us,
but drawn in to examine and to
re-examine that evidence by the
problems which we ourselves feel
the need to understand.
Each of us is drawn,
almost instinctively,
to those aspects of the past
which continue to resonate to us
individually across the
centuries because they speak to
us for reasons we sometimes
might not fully understand.
They speak to our
preoccupations,
they speak to our dilemmas.
And in trying to understand
them, we can not only understand
ourselves better in time,
but also see possibilities for
the future.
Historical events can often be
dismaying, but historical study
is ultimately encouraging;
it's concerned with change,
with possibility,
with adaptation,
with finding ways.
It's concerned with human
experience and achievement of
every kind.
Sustaining a sense of that
ancestry is important in what
sometimes seems an increasingly
frivolous and de-historicized
Western culture with an
extremely shallow awareness of
its own past that can result in
a kind of disorientation.
History, in contrast,
tries to understand;
to understand what we have
been, to raise questions and
suggestions and implications for
what we might be capable of
becoming.
And that's why history,
all history,
matters.
It really does matter.
Okay, well that's my little
sermon, and now we're going to
have a short awards ceremony,
for which I must prepare
myself.
>
Right.
I hereby declare myself Supreme
Head of the History Department.
Henceforward only my
interpretations will be taught,
and henceforward,
all books published by members
of the Department will contain a
groveling dedication to me.
>
But even the most horrid tyrant
cannot rule alone.
You need an aristocracy.
>
And aristocracies,
as you know,
need to be rewarded.
And so we have an awards
ceremony to reward our teaching
fellows;
the russet-coated captains of
this course who (laughs) know
what they teach and love what
they know.
Okay, now I have some
nominations for these awards
here prepared for me by Thomas
Cromwell.
>
Right.
Now, first of all,
what do we have here?
Yes, okay.
We have the Henry VIII Award
for Devotion to Family Values
and for being top redhead.
>
Student:
Oh, thank you
>
It's a divorced,
beheaded, died,
divorced, beheaded,
survived bag,
which I will use for my library
books for my work.
Keith Wrightson:  Okay.
And now we have the Elizabeth I
Award for Not Making Windows
into Students' Souls and for
Keeping Advisors in their Place.
<<Laughter and
applause>>
And looking ahead to the Stuart
Succession which I've done my
best to avoid,
but unfortunately it's going to
happen,
so my soothsayers tell me,
we have the King Charles II
Award --
the last real king -- the King
Charles II Award for Being Tall,
Dark and Partly French --
>
-- and for staying cool
and carrying on.
To Justin DuRivage.
>
Okay.
So that's it.
>
Do remember to let me know if
you intend to come to the Center
for British Art tomorrow morning
for the last visit there and now
we'll turn to housekeeping
matters and I'll tell you a
little bit about the nature of
the exam.